okay you ready yeah where are you
yeah there you go
I haven't kissed that many girls but uh
again the ones I have need some more
than just kissing so I'm pretty
confident so I choose my battles wisely
you know I could kiss everybody I could
kiss literally anyone on the street
however I choose not to because it's
against the law
I don't know how to follow that up I
think most of the battles of my big lips
carry uh most things you know when you
go to a car dealership you go in there
expecting like um something nice
something like premium based you don't
go to like a key owl like maybe like a
Toyota or something like that mine is
like that just go into like a Tesla for
example like a Porsche very selective
and go for the premium brand my
experience is very limited okay very
picky when it comes to women uh just
because you know we're all adults now we
need some emotional maturity but yeah
when it comes down to it they can handle
pretty well and my boy over here seems
confident yeah yeah yeah then you should
go you should come second yeah yeah you
got me on the drip though
second second the law is holding you
back uh so what kind of techniques do
you guys use when you you kiss you're
about to my kind of girl I don't know
about technique but I got a special move
I could leave a hickey with no Mark so
you know that that came from dealing
with uh strict parents for the girls you
know
I'm not gonna pull out like a few combos
every now and then you know I feel like
I give them like the uh the old tongue
twister
and then you know hit him with the hit
him with the left bottom bite
oh that's crazy that's kind of like
those are my my kind of combos okay but
then I kind of like to finish it off
with a good high five or like a fist
bump or something about VC for that I
mean I don't really have a couple moves
or techniques I just kind of follow
because I'm never sure how they how they
want to go like too fast too slow so
I'll like do the 90 10 I'll get him part
way they they lead and then I follow
their example that's how I usually do it
show them that one move you do with your
face before
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm looking I'm like damn they're kind
of cute
[Music]
should I just kiss them that was kind of
my uh my whole
mindset there
um okay make the face that you make when
you go to kiss someone
do you like tongue I do but not like
don't like try to like
feed me your tongue like I like little
spurts here and there I actually don't
like tongue really so like we might have
very different tastes I don't know I
kind of I mean if you like you know
stick it in there feeling a little bit
more like about the hands and like you
know what you're doing there and then
I'm definitely I like it slow yeah I
like it like not really any tongue yeah
um and more like suck on my lip bite my
lip you know don't bite it off about it
like you could pull my hair choke me
whatever but like don't like bite my
mouth like I hate that I hate that so
much you guys make the face that guys
make when they go to kiss you
or
before we get into the kisses make sure
to like this video And subscribe to our
sister Channel nectar for all your love
and dating content now let's get back to
kissing
[Music]
how are you feeling going into the
kisses I mean it's you know a little
nervous but it is what it is you know
I'm confident in my muscle memory so
we'll see how that goes
how you doing
are you ready sure
how you doing good how are you chilling
something you ready to go yeah yeah
how did you feel about a
um I wouldn't say like best kiss I've
ever had but I liked A's confidence yeah
because he was he knew what to do yeah
hands like grab whatever placement
everything yeah I could leave a hickey
with no mark
what
yeah yeah oh my God I was gonna like
wipe it but I didn't want to like I was
debating in my head I was like okay do I
wipe it and like make him feel bad or
like do I say something and say like oh
I just want to do it to clean the Slate
after a I like was desperately wiping my
lip because I felt it like all over it
took too long to debate I wanted to do
it but then I was like oops the guy's
already here yeah
how are you feeling pretty confident I
think uh yeah I think I got this man I
uh really do you know I'm gonna put my
big boy pants on for once and just kind
of kind of do it guy B you can step up
you ready yeah where are you
yeah yeah no you're good
you ready yeah okay
it was oh
yeah yeah
it was yeah yeah
um very very fast it was fast it was
hard yeah like like I don't know how it
was hard yeah
what are some feelings you're having
going into each kiss I'm really nervous
I have no idea what to expect but I'm
excited either way
ready
you ready yeah
yeah
load a little better than b yeah but I
still kind of felt it was very
less lip more like I don't know
I don't know I feel like she had
potential but for some reason it just
wasn't there the only person who gave me
tongue really was a I think any of them
gave me tongue really yeah I have
nostrology in mind just like going
landing and just get it done that's
that's pretty much it there's no need to
like overthink anything just just go for
it
already
girl that was interesting I gotta ask
I've been biting my tongue what was your
experience with the last guy pretty good
actually I need a vent he stopped early
oh really yeah like really fast
like everybody else like waited like the
time but then he just like walked away
like how long would you say
I don't know three five yeah that's what
it felt like really yeah I'm like okay
so I guess he's not feeling it not
feeling me whatever but it was like yeah
okay
I think
D if it was like if he was more
comfortable I feel like it would have
been a lot better
[Music]
I don't know like it was so short you
have potential to be like high but like
pardon me is like Petty I thought it was
petty but I just feel like like I mean I
just wasn't long enough either for me to
really be able to help I feel like he
could have like I want to make him last
is there anyone that you would want to
extend a kiss with go a little longer
the thing it means there is
I think it's truly between
okay
what's up
uh you're the worst for us let's go
um a tip I don't know it's gonna sound
mean but your lips are like kind of hard
and I don't know how you did that but
however you did that it's adjusted a
little bit okay well like my trick
though
I come with the hard and iconic go soft
over yeah over like I'd say an hour
period of time yeah I'm like a long
distance runner for sure so okay okay
yeah I would just adjust that thank you
very cute though
thank you
last
like fourth mm-hmm
okay okay see
how's it going hi
um I think that for you like it wasn't
bad
um like of course but like it I think it
was just maybe like kind of kind of the
same thing with him but like not the
speed more just maybe like soften the
lips but otherwise I feel like it was it
was fine thank you I feel like you have
potential I feel like you're kind of
nervous a little bit yeah it makes sense
obviously I mean you can tell it's okay
thank you I mean all I got was uh softer
lips so injections bam I'm kidding
I feel like you're really slow and
you're pretty like
pansy which I liked
um I would just say you could follow
like a give and take more like if you
notice your partner is like bringing in
tongue you can bring that into if you're
comfortable with that if you're not
comfortable that's fine for me
um I think you don't like me which is
totally fine I if you're not into it
um you left really quickly in the kiss
um so I kind of just took that as it is
no problemo
um but you left a kiss really fast so I
kind of feel like you don't like me
okay
uh that's not true by the way because it
was because I was very very like
uncomfortable like kissing like you guys
yeah yeah okay
I do I mean talking to you right now I
do like you I mean
just like just like okay
no but um thank you
um yeah I want to do way too long
because then it's gonna kind of like a
getting a little bit weird so you're
ranked second are you surprised at that
ranking no because I know I'm a good
kisser I would have been first if I
kissed a first girl longer but like I
said I was a bit nervous
the number one
um a
h
uh you're really soft really gently slow
you're really touchy which I liked
um it was really wet
um that's not a bad thing but I would
just like be aware of that
um and it wasn't like complete slobber
City where like it like it you know
there is room you had the most
confidence in your kiss like you knew
like you know where like speed where to
grab like you know what would
potentially turn on a girl so
appreciate it
y'all were wonderful I can't complain so
I mean I've been sure yeah would you
want to kiss out of the girls again
I mean
whatever you know like whatever it is
man I mean I'm not forcing nothing so it
is what it is
guys do you have any notes for the girls
God
no no it's they don't want to hurt our
feelings we still got one Note One
oh
I don't know like it was it wasn't bad
like at all
[Music]
[Laughter]
it wasn't I think there's room for
improvement depending on who like is
your partner like who you are romantic
with affectionate with whatever I think
if you and your partner have good
communication and you can talk through
what works and what doesn't work I think
there's always room for change with that
would you want to kiss either of the
girls again
probably not man uh like I'm not I'm not
big on kissing man I like I kind of get
to the point with like with like maybe
like a head bump or like a high five or
something so I'm not like a big kisser
so no I wouldn't